$20 million Victoria Secrets fashion
show it came to London it came last
night the company's underwear is Big
Business Victoria Secrets turned over
$6.6 billion last year it operates a
thousand stores Bloomberg caught up with
the CEO Sharon J
attorney you know what it's very
exciting for us as being an
international brand and uh we opened our
store over three years ago here on Bond
Street and it's just such a wonderful
feeling to be here and you know it's one
of the fashion capitals too being in
London and last night they had uh the
London Fashion Awards and so we were
there and helped them raise about
$75,000 for you know to bring new kids
into this fashion work so very exciting
to be here and very exciting to be in
London with Christmas around the corner
it's the most important time of the year
for retailers across the world after an
underwhelming Black Friday we asked the
CEO if she was still optimistic for the
holiday season
you know I think that we're cautiously
optimistic we know we're excited about
what's going on for Holiday we're very
well prepared for what's happening for
holiday so all in all I think that we
are going to stay optimistic uh for this
holiday season